which well first of all for people who
don't know uh where are you from how
long you've been rapping you've
obviously been doing your thing for a
very long time a long time I'm from East
Sacramento Lincoln Village is out there
in Rancho
uh I've been rapping since I was 15. I'm
32 right now so so you've been at it
yeah can we get you closer to the mic if
you don't mind please
um so yeah [ __ ] that's 17 years of
rapping yeah sure and I was rapping
before that but that's when I first
recorded right I got I've been trying to
rap like my whole life for real what um
do you remember like uh when you first
kind of realized you could kind of make
a living off of rap music or like get
some serious money doing this [ __ ]
when was that
that was about 12 years ago now
what was that was that prior to him
getting because there's the time he got
locked up and then when he got like I
every time I talked like we've talked
like he's like yo there was a time he
went to prison and it really kind of
like made him readjust the way he
thought about his music career before
that okay so it was before that yeah
so he was he was gonna buy his other
name
yeah so once you guys Linked UP what was
the difference in terms of like you sent
me how to uh with the CD Baby [ __ ] so I
never I just was putting my [ __ ] on Hulk
cheer just on the on the [ __ ]
download sites yeah just download zshare
and all Hulk sharing yeah all that type
of [ __ ] yeah
by then he told me how to do the CD Baby
[ __ ] yeah cause CD Baby was kind of like
the OG version of like what Empire does
now or yeah what's you know it's like a
way to get your [ __ ] distributed yeah
I'm just gonna check on another day
yeah that's what I was [ __ ] with I
did that I did the little CD Baby I made
my first little 300. that was a lot
because I ain't never been of course so
I'm like oh [ __ ] so I was really that
made me just start dropping [ __ ] more on
there hmm I built my little [ __ ] up all
the time I was gonna say like that's one
thing that um I think that like mozzie
has done successfully over the years is
just like build up an independent
catalog for sure whether it's like doing
random collab projects with like a gun
play or a burner or whatever it is but
just continuing to just rack up catalogs
that's something that you kind of also
took from him for sure yeah I've been I
was dropping a hell of projects like
that but I'd be trying to I'd be trying
to keep up at the same time baby move he
was moving too fast at the time yeah so
and then I was going in and out of jail
so I was I was held back by that too